foreign
I Know Who You Are
the serial killer
say to him no more killing or we go to
the cops we could
we get a murderer speaks no based on a
true story yes yes yes yes yes
why are people obsessed with True Crime
because it's real and it takes you out
of your own miserable life behind the
white picket fence like there's that ear
with the ants on it like we all feel
like we're living in a normal life we're
a couple that's a little lost we've
never been in the game what game you're
not the guy I married the marriage not a
great place I think they're all in need
of a change in their lives she thought
we were having a three-way I did I do
what she's pregnant really that's that's
the reason why we're not tell us about
your character my character is a single
dad he doesn't feel appreciated he
doesn't feel seen and when he meets
these two guys he just feels a lot
better about himself hot plumber
they seize an opportunity that maybe not
many people would seize it was insane
that we thought we could control that
psychopath
everybody's obsessed with True Crime the
way we are I'm having a wine and crime
night with the girls tonight can you go
out for a few hours if you've met a
killer would you be friends with him did
you do my back absolutely [__] not
it's the burning question we all
struggle with
talk
[Music]
honestly also weirdly funny you know
what you're gonna get me back
we've had a lot of fun in this show no
we actually have mainly because of this
this woman right here
can we do that again I love you and I
don't want to fight
literally one of the most fun jobs I've
ever had
just a little scary at times should I
run because
they know where we live entertaining
should we use that word yeah we could
Rock 15 million views
please remember to press record oh
really